hi did you this is cherry cream i'm the
founder of net vibe and now the new sea
of a new company called Java cloud and
I'm pretty excited about Obama
presidency I think there's lots to be
told about the way he won and the way he
actually put what I believe I the most
important things the unit and ecology at
the top of the agenda administration and
in a way I just hope that Europe would
be able to have the same kind of Europe
in the rest of the way the same kind of
direction so I I think the Obama is the
president of the United States so it's
really going to focus on this country
but I believe that it's the old world is
looking for some kind of calm down here
at the time now we need to focus on
things but I'm immoral without really
targeted to help the people around the
world and I think that part of what he's
going to do will definitely help the
world going further and and obviously
there's lots of hope who has there's a
lot of hope in in the rest of the world
there's not a magician meaning that he
won't be able to fix everything but I
think that if you set the standard bar
very high there's an opportunity for
doing quite amazing things and I'm
pretty confident he wouldn't do it